let's get more on this story from DW
reporter and native day and Peter doll
welcome
so we there Prime Minister there's like
a schoolteacher so I'm not angry
disappointed and what else have you been
hearing well
the Prime Minister may not be angry but
a lot of people certainly are they see
this as completely disrespectful the
former speaker of the Danish Parliament
Pia kaskell tweeted not long ago well
I'll be President Trump
cancels his visit via Twitter because we
won't sell Greenland what an insolent
way to treat the Danish people and the
Queen who invited him complete lack of
respect and class others see this as a
huge blow to partnership that's
historically been very strong a head of
the Danish social Liberal Party
motorcycle went as far as saying this
has proved that the United States under
President Trump simply can't be trusted
he's saying in a tweet their reality
Trump's fiction anyone in the US State
Department could've told Trump the
answer to this question this is
preposterous and it shows why now more
than ever we should view the EU members
as our closest allies the man is
completely erratic so you can say you no
other there's also a sense of relief
Trump is not particularly well-liked and
Denmark I was there just a few weeks ago
when they were discussing his visiting
in the with a Danish public broadcaster
and the audience I think seventy percent
say he should stay away but I think more
than anything this means like Denmark
has been giving kind of the Trump
treatment this is kind of what he does
in a way he aims he sets the bar
incredibly high he makes these
provocative statements and then he takes
it from their stars negotiating this
would you look at you think well how did
it come to this well why was he
interested in buying in the first place
and what made him think they wanted to
sell it well it's not quite clear why he
all of a sudden set his sights on
Greenland in the first place it's it's
not a completely novel idea though I
mean at the end of World War Two in 1946
President Harry Truman at the time
offered to buy Greenland for 100 million
dollars do you politically it makes a
lot of sense it's strategically it's
closer to Russia um it would allow the
u.s. to kind of keep an eye on China now
also but more importantly what we're
seeing with especially global warming
the Arctic is that there are masses of
resource that are all of a sudden now
opening up and Greenland would be
perfectly placed to start tapping into
them and that also very much fits in the
mo of a president Trump so has any good
come out of this well I think in the
sense that in Denmark at least has
started a debate about the Denmark's
relationship to Greenland it has been a
kind of trouble relationship colonialism
the Greenland is feeling like they
haven't really been taken seriously and
I think I've heard some members
Greenlanders members of the Danish
Parliament today saying well maybe we
need to you know use this to put more
pressure on Denmark and and try to get
them to treat us also with a bit more
respectful and you know where we're hot
at Margaret now so let's start that
process with you teaching us that the
Danish for goodbye yes hi hi oh that's
easy
hi hi yeah Peter go